so then a large fire has broken out at
south africa's parliament building in
cape town it's said to have started in
offices but flames have now spread to
the national assembly building an
emergency services spokesman says cracks
have been forming in the building's
we walls the situation under control for
now
um we will be continuing with the
investigation as to the cause of the
fire
for now where it is burning we've
contained the fire in the chambers of
the national council of provinces the
fire is currently in the national
assembly chambers where we are also busy
to contain that this is a very sad day
for our democracy because parliament is
the home of our democracy
well let's get more on this from julian
wolfe who joins us on the line from cape
town and jillian what are you hearing on
the ground what's the latest
hi nick yeah so the woman you just
featured in your broadcast i spoke with
her patricia de liu uh she's the
minister of public works and former
mayor here of cape town and she told me
that there's an investigation underway
whereby they're speaking with the
firefighting teams the first responders
parliament security and police in order
to determine what the cause of the fire
actually was because they they're
unaware of that at the moment but
they're managing the situation it's uh
they've been able to con contain the
fire in the chambers of the
national council of provinces but has
spread to the national assembly chambers
and uh that's what they're busy doing
right now is trying to get that under
control uh the fire ignited early this
morning and i'm being told that
firefighters were on the scene within
four minutes there was about four um one
of 30 of them and uh they're doing
everything that they can to get the fire
under control thankfully no one has been
injured and first responders have moved
everyone as far away from the parliament
as possible until the fire is contained
and julian the building itself a
significant part of the city
yeah that's true so both institutions
are super important institutions of
democracy here in south africa in the
national assembly where the fire has
spread to is an iconic building here in
south africa it's where the members of
parliament meet and debate and they ask
their questions to ministers and it's uh
where the president girl ramaphosa also
delivers the state of the nation address
it's also very significant as it's where
nelson mandela was elected as the first
president of south africa's new
democracy so this is where he delivered
his first address to the nation and uh
south africa has also been addressed by
many other heads of state in that
building including former president u.s
bill uh us
president bill clinton and and other
world leaders so it's it's a place where
the nation watches its democracy unfold
and its democracy in action and um of
course it's a monument that attracts
many tourists from all over the world
all right julian we'll leave it there
for the moment thanks for that julian
wolf there joining us from cape town